[Music]
English lessons hi everyone welcome
today's English mini lesson hang on mini
English lesson how do you know what
order to put the adjectives if there's a
specific adjective order that we always
use the best way to remember it is using
an acronym so the acronym is orange
skies and shady clouds on my pillow the
first word is orange now that's going to
stand for opinion what we think of an
object is going to come first because
that's the most important thing
the second is skies now that's going to
stand for size skies size it rise how
big or small something is the third and
stands for age how old is something is
young the forest is shady now that is
the shape of something
is it rectangular is it oval is it round
so the fifth word is clouds now that
stands for color things like red blue
magenta magenta even a color let's just
roll with it next word is on now that's
gonna stand for origin where does this
thing come from where is this person
come from what is their nationality are
they great like me are they French like
you who knows the M&Y is for material
what is it made of
is it cloth is a plastic is it ceramic
the last word in our acronym was pillow
now that stands for purpose why do we
use this object is it a sleeping bag is
it a frying pan so we've got an acronym
let's put it into practice now is it a
handsome young frenchman or is it a
French young handsome man let's go to
our afternoon to see orange skies and
shady clouds on my pillow first one
opinion we said it's the most important
handsome second young it's his age third
French that's his nationality and lastly
you've got your noun the man handsome
young Frenchman how do you like my
expensive new black leather jacket or is
it my leather black new expensive jacket
so let's have a look at our acronym
again orange skies and shady clouds on
my pillar number one expensive that's an
opinion for some people something is
expensive for others it isn't number two
new that's the age number three black
that's obviously the color number four
leather the material so it's an
expensive new black leather jacket so
that concludes our lesson today guys
thanks for watching hope the acronym
helps you out I'm off to try my
expensive new black leather jacket
[Music]